l'appartement refuge numérotée le
voisinage anonyme le mode de vie
compartimentée rendent de plus en plus
nécessaire les lieux de rencontre pour
les individus nombreux sont ceux qui ont
gardé la nostalgie du village où le mot
communauté avait un sens il voulait dire
chaleur contact entrait de joie partagée
tout ce que notre civilisation détruit
petit à petit
d'aucuns ont cherché à rétablir ces
échanges nécessaires au bon équilibre de
l'homme ainsi sont nés les centres
socioculturels
quatre de ces centres à laval ont
organisé dimanche une journée portes
ouvertes afin de faire connaître tout
d'abord leur existence et aussi les
possibilités d'action qu'ils ont ce sont
les fourches place pasteur
hiller blast hiller les pommeraies rue
hébert et ça nicolas boulevard
kellermann
les gens sont venus moins nombreux que
souhaiter peut-être car ces centres sont
la sphère de tous les habitants qui sont
invités à réfléchir et à agir pour
l'évolution de la vie du quartier
les familles les différents groupes
sociaux les individus de tous âges
doivent s'y rencontrer et tous sont
chargés de la gestion administrative et
de l'animation à tous les niveaux
les activités et les services sont
organisées selon leurs souhaits et leurs
besoins
les visiteurs ont pu se rendre compte
que de nombreuses possibilités leur
était déjà offerte dans chacun des
quatre centres de lavage des services
médico sociaux fonctionnent permanence
médicale vaccination garderie formation
ménagères ainsi qu'un vaste choix
d'activités culturelles sportives et
loisirs
chaque centre possède une bibliothèque
des ateliers de bricolage peinture
céramique des clubs des équipes
sportives en fait tout ce qui est
susceptible d'épanouir l'homme en lui
donnant la possibilité de se cultiver de
développer ces dons et de découvrir les
autres
ces centres socioculturels fonctionne
avec le concours de la caisse
d'allocations familiales de la mayenne
de la ville de laval et de la direction
de l'action sanitaire et sociale une
nouvelle annexe au centre saint nicolas
et est actuellement en construction vous
le verge urbain